[Music]
a custom program with the graduate
school of business
is a highly immersive and engaging
online educational experience for
executives it is different from many
other online experiences because it's
high touch
because it is so immersive and because
the participants
and the faculty are highly engaged this
is not just a standard
online program this is really a way of
immersing yourself in the stanford
community high engagement
high touch opportunity to really engage
with the material
and learn in a strategic way when a
company or an organization works with us
we've designed the content to meet their
needs in a very human centered way
the faculty director works very very
closely with the client
to determine what the content is going
to be
who's going to teach in the program and
what other kinds of added benefits there
might be
the best thing about teaching online is
that it requires
one as an educator to get to the point
of the matter and to distill what the
learning
is into very small chunks
it combines our leading faculty
immersive technology
and innovative pedagogy it requires
engagement
it requires participating and learning
from others as well as teaching
others it's highly interactive and
that's the best way to learn